this week
on brian ross investigates while an
angry and glum
president ponders his future if you
count the illegal votes
they can try to steal
the election from us prosecutors are
working on criminal cases that could put
donald trump
and his family and his company in
serious jeopardy
we're joined by pulitzer prize-winning
journalist and author david k
johnston donald trump could somehow end
up in prison
is that realistic it's certainly
realistic that he will end up
convicted of crimes plus inside the
growing
white nationalist movement in this
country
the photojournalist who was there for
some of america's ugliest moments in
recent history
tells us what he saw and what he sees
next
i would love to stop but i i can't
possibly
um knowing that these groups are still
out there
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
from the editors of mediaite calling the
election
cnn projects joseph r biden jr is
elected
the 46th president of the united states
repeated false claims i think that it is
a
corrupt stolen election from the law and
crime trial network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thanks for joining us
and welcome to our viewers on facebook
live
i'm brian ross joined as always tonight
by rhonda schwartz my colleague of law
and crime
and rhonda we begin with the drama in
washington as president
trump continues to maintain the election
was stolen from him and he refuses to
concede to joseph biden
no one likes to be a loser but there's
something else at play here for donald
trump
the fact that he knows he his family and
his company are under serious criminal
investigation rhonda
that's right as president donald trump
has faced
enjoyed immunity from prosecution it's
justice department policy that you
cannot indict a sitting president
but all that changes on january 20th
when president trump becomes citizen
trump brian
to learn more about this we're now
joined by david k johnston the
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
reporter author of four books two of
them on trump
and co-founder of dc report david thank
you so much for joining us we're talking
about the prospect that donald trump
could somehow end up in prison is that
realistic
uh it's certainly realistic that he will
end up convicted of
crimes uh by the time he would get to
sentencing i expect like
general pinochet of chile he would show
up in court in a wheelchair and
cleaning that he's a sick old man to get
house arrest
what are the most significant
investigations which one do you think
has the most heft
well the current one that's in the front
is the new york
city or new york county grand jury
they have been looking for some time
into bank insurance and tax fraud
and all they're lacking are the records
of his accounting firm
which trump has now twice been to the
supreme court
trying to stop they will eventually get
those records and i expect he'll be
indicted
second the new york state attorney
general has a civil investigation
underway but that could morph
into a racketeering charge against trump
and the trump organization
and if that were to happen upon
indictment
prosecutors could seize uh his assets
like mar-a-lago and trump tower and his
golf courses
as the fruit of a criminal enterprise
he faces real trouble a question for you
david from ronda schwartz rhonda
david if these prosecutions go forward
won't it just seem like politically
motivated revenge and undercut the
validity of all this
well it certainly will play that way
with some people but here's the
important thing about the grand jury
investigation
in manhattan it's for things trump did
before he took
office going back to 2011.
and it's not the federal government
doing it it's the state
government and he's all the way along
uh fought disclosure of
documents the grand jury should have
gotten a long time ago so yes i'm sure
donald will complain this is some on
improper vengeance just like he won't
acknowledge that he's lost the election
but it's a garden variety fraud
investigation
covering many years of conduct and let's
keep in mind that
story i broke four years ago donald has
already been tried
twice the past for civil tax fraud
he lost both of those cases and his own
witness revealed
at that hearing that he is a forger he
forged his own tax return and put his
tax lawyer's
name on it in order to
wrongfully claim uh six hundred thousand
dollars in tax losses
let me follow up on that david also the
u.s attorney's office in the southern
district of manhattan in new york part
of the federal justice department
has a potential case against him would
that seem like a political revenge under
a bite administration
yeah that's the one that is the easiest
to prove and yet the most problematic
politically
uh michael cohen went to prison and is
still under house arrest
for crimes that he did at the direction
of individual one who has since been
identified as donald trump
so if michael cohen is properly a felon
and in prison then donald trump
should be prosecuted but because it's
the federal government
that is the one charge that he can
scream loudest about
is uh revenge by the democrats or biden
or whomever it is he wants to accuse
even though it's the easiest to prove
it's a slam dunk
let me ask you about the prospect of a
pardon pardons he might grant and
perhaps pardon himself
even though that wouldn't keep him clear
from the state charges but what about
that notion
we expect a number of pardons to come in
the next two and a half months and could
he pardon himself
well he will certainly issue a lot of
pardons particularly to
his daughter ivanka and her husband
jared kushner who
faces some real serious problems
otherwise
i think the u.s supreme court ruling on
access to his accounting records in july
in which chief justice roberts wrote
that no man is above the law
makes it very clear he cannot pardon
himself and the supreme court will not
uphold such a pardon on the other hand
he could potentially resign as president
let's say on the morning of
january 20th mike pence would be sworn
in as president
pence could then pardon him there are
two problems with that approach
uh one is the supreme court might decide
that that's a sham
and not uh have it stand they might also
take the view that
the president has the power to do this
but mike pence would be subject to
prosecution for bribery
because conducting an official act
in return for anything of value
is a crime well being president of the
united states even if it's for one hour
is something of value
and were mike pence to do that i think
we would all be shocked if he was not
prosecuted
let me ask you just to follow up there
for our viewers a pardon can be granted
for instance for his children
in advance of any charges doesn't have
to be a pending charge so there would be
a pardon
well that's an untested idea
but gerald ford gave a pardon to richard
nixon
for all crimes he may have committed
and of course richard nixon's tax lawyer
went to prison
over his fraudulent tax returns
i think a blanket pardon would probably
be upheld by the supreme court
but remember this under a 1925 u.s
supreme court decision called
burdick the acceptance of a pardon which
is optional you can reject a pardon
as burdick did on ethical grounds means
that you are confessing that you have
committed offenses against the united
states
so if you accept a pardon everybody else
can reasonably call you for the rest of
your life
a criminal
fascinating insight so bottom line here
he faces
a world of hurt oh his life is going to
be absolutely miserable once he loses
the protections and privileges
of being president because in addition
to this he's got
uh more than two dozen women pressing
uh sexual assault and rape civil cases
against him
and the most troubling one of those for
him is the writer eg
carroll who was a writer at saturday
night live at one time
who kept the clothes she was wearing
when she says
donald raped her and she has been
seeking his dna
if she gets his dna and it matches up
just as with bill clinton and monica
lewinsky's blue dress
he's in a world of hurt
another dress david k johnson once again
thank you so much for joining us tonight
thank you
coming up next a rare inside look at the
growing white
nationalist movement in this country an
ugly legacy of the trump era
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law on crime
trial network
well so far fears of violence after the
election have not come to be
even so the fbi continues to take a
close look at a number of groups that
all too often have threatened to take
some kind of action
an ugly undeniable legacy of the
presidency of donald trump
the growth of extremist groups like this
one marching to the lincoln memorial
in washington dc all documented by
photojournalist
zach roberts it's a far-right white
nationalist group called
uh patriot front and if you notice in
some of the flags and that sort of thing
in the photos in the video they actually
have a fascist
uh which is an old roman you know kind
of age-old symbol
of uh you know empire and that sort of
thing and
they crossed the bridge saying reclaim
america reclaim america
and marched right through right up the
mall right up to the capitol building
and what is their reaction to having you
there somebody who's not part of the
group how did you fit in or did you fit
in
one of the things that i do when i cover
rallies is that i
you know i get people's faces i try to
document who they are to try to find out
more about these groups
you've done amazing work sort of getting
inside these groups covering them so
well
let's talk about what you saw in
charlottesville that famed march
they lit up the torches and moved
through all of those buildings that have
such a
they you know some of them are designed
by thomas jefferson
and they were marching through that you
know yelling jews will not replace us
you know they will not replace us you
know and you know all
in unison um and they
it was it was one of the more terrifying
moments in my life i think that
the night in charlottesville the tiki
torch march uh
shook me more than
in that everything but you also had
people that were
very fine people on both sides then you
have donald trump saying
that you know they're good people on
both sides i didn't meet any good people
on one side um these people were not you
know not for what america stands for
the next day roberts was there when some
of them attacked a 21 year old teaching
assistant
by the name of deandre harris they
literally broke uh he they pushed him
into the parking arm
of the garage and then one of them
picked up that parking arm and started
beating him
brutally with it i actually uh showed
photos of that to
a trooper that was right outside there
while they were still there the people
who had attacked him several of them
were still there
and i said this just happened and the
police officer the trooper just shrugged
his shoulders and said
what are you gonna do and those photos
became important evidence
yes yeah thankfully um those photos have
published them
sean king and a whole bunch of other
activists um basically
went on the web and said okay we're
gonna find these guys and they found
them
and thankfully um four people uh were
tried and convicted
and they are now at least i think about
five to ten years in prison
this was one of my first times that i
realized um
you know when i became a photojournalist
i thought okay you know i'm gonna cover
cover this sort of thing overseas i'm
gonna cover you know i grew up
uh watching you watching you know
watching uh you know yugoslavia watching
you know all these all these
all these wars and i'm like okay i'm
gonna go cover that i'll have to wear a
bulletproof vest and a helmet and a you
know all this gear
right now in my in my uh car uh i carry
everywhere i go
i have a ballistic helmet i have a
bulletproof vest and i have two
different types of gas masks
roberts was in philadelphia last week
covering election protests
when authorities said they broke up a
plot to attack
the vote counting headquarters
philadelphia police arrest
61-year-old antonio lamotta one of two
virginia men caught outside the
pennsylvania convention center
armed with handguns so how did the
authorities get on to this plot
from there's not i've actually i
literally just got off the phone before
i i talked to you with uh
uh with my with my contacts about this
with q anon
um i never like to assume mental health
issues but
it is a it is a it is a cult that
um is ready to die at any given moment
for it the people that accelerate to
that point that they're able that
they're willing to get into a car
drive up to a different uh across states
it with arms
uh guns in their uh guns in their car
and go
that that is a moment because inevitably
they will get confronted by police
and that's when something something will
happen let me ask you this
with former vice president biden now
likely the
president-elect what do you think is
going to happen
in the next three months before the
inauguration
that that is the big if that every
single almost every conversation that i
have with people who cover this
uh you know my colleague friends and
colleagues and my sources that we're
constantly asking and
you know if donald trump comes out and
continually beats the drum
that it was stolen from him that this
isn't right or whatever
that's when i think that we'll have a
lot more of
these kind of this q anon you know kunan
incident that happened
you know almost happened at least at uh
at the convention center
and you're going to continue to cover
even with the threats and the risks that
you run
uh absolutely uh unfortunately this has
become um
i would love to i would love to stop but
i i can't possibly
um knowing that this these groups are
still out there um
and that um um that
they they're not going to go away even
if joe even if joe bond wins and nothing
happens over the three months
the the proud boys you know uh patriot
front all these groups are still going
to be out there
and you're going to be you're going to
see them on a local level and in
different ways
still organizing and they're not going
to go away in either one
zach roberts thank you so much for
joining us and a salute to your bravery
and your skill
as a photojournalist thank you so much
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
taking stock one week after the election
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law on crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined as always by aidan
mclaughlin who's the editor chief of
mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network is part of the dan abrams media
empire
aidan thanks for being here this week in
the midst of all the election news you
chose your first winner
as the ceo of the pfizer drug company
with some very
welcome news for everyone
it is a great day for science it is a
great
day for humanity when you realize that
your vaccine has a 90 effectiveness
that's overwhelming uh you understand
that the hopes of billions of people and
millions and
businesses and hundreds of governments
that were
felt on our shoulders now we can
credibly threat them i think we can see
light at the end of the time
very welcome news aiden everyone was
saluting that including wall street
yeah so that's right you know it's you
make a good point there it was a really
crazy week in news i think everyone was
focused on the election until we had
this announcement from pfizer
on monday uh that they had uh had a
breakthrough in the phase three
chronovirus trials
um and had a vaccine that's showing 90
percent
efficacy which is a really astonishing
development uh
you know the coronavirus pandemic is the
biggest story of the year and the fact
that pfizer has made this breakthrough
is really welcome news and now you have
uh dr anthony fauci saying that we
really could have
a vaccine being distributed to people by
the end of the year so
uh the uh ceo of pfizer appeared on
squawk box the cnbc show
and did a really lengthy interview
lasted about 30 minutes
and it was fascinating he answered all
their questions and
and it revealed a lot about where the
state of the vaccine
uh developments are right now he did a
later interview on cnn but we really
thought the cnbc one was
the most fascinating the most uh
informative um so
yeah that made for a good winner this
week
absolutely and for loser back to fox
news brian kilmeade
fanning the fans of conspiracy theories
let's take a look at that
he wants to recount some of them he's
probably going to get in wisconsin
probably going to get in georgia
he also has a situation where he's got
legal teams fanned out
in all these states for example sydney
powell comes out and said yesterday
there were 450 000 ballots found
with only biden's name on it that
bothers the president i'm sure
there's a software called hammer and
scorecard used to flip votes
from trump to biden is that indeed true
don't you think if you're the president
united states you'd like to find out
all that's missing there is some proof
or evidence aidan
yep yeah so you know we've seen a truly
shocking amount of conspiracy theories
and false claims
regarding election fraud get floated on
social media and make their way up to
fox news in the last few days
now to fox news's credit uh uh
most of their anchors and reporters have
done a good job of dispelling unproven
rumors about the election
which the network says that joe biden
has won the opinion hosts are a
different story
uh fox and friends co-host brian kilmood
who we saw just there
on monday he gave air time to this
allegation from uh
pro-trump lawyers uh that a computer
program named hammer and scorecard
were used to flip votes from trump to
buy it now
that conspiracy theory was debunked we
know it's not true
uh and you know i think brian kilmer
will maintain that he was just asking a
question there he was just loading an
allegation to his audience
he wasn't saying whether it was true or
not but you know
i think news people have a higher burden
uh when they make an allegation like
that i can't just go
on fox and friends and say you know
steve ducey might be a lizard person
i'm just asking questions you know you
actually have to have some evidence
to prove these things particularly if
you're in the news business um so
you know brian kelly is just one of the
fox news opinion hosts
who have been getting hot behind
president donald trump's claims that the
election was stolen from him
they've done it to varying degrees but
it's certainly not
good conduct for news people who should
be looking at this and saying
before they make a conclusion where's
the evidence or before they even ask
questions about something that
is so clearly a conspiracy theory that
it's already been debunked
and overall aiden we have one minute
left here how do you judge the overall
performance of the media during this
election week and
counting the votes you know i think the
media has done a really good job i think
there was a huge burden on the media
in the week running up to the election
you know you saw all these hosts saying
you know we have to be really patient
and cautious which is not something that
cable news is known for
uh you know we have to remind our
audience that like the election could
take days could take a week
uh that we're not going to know the
results on election night and i think a
lot of
their audience were prepared for that
and and the the cable news networks in
particular did a good job of
having patience in making any sort of
declaration uh
now i think there's also a weird holding
pattern where
the media has declared joe biden the
projected winner of the election
and president trump and a lot of his
party is refusing to acknowledge that
it's going to be wild to see how that
develops because there's going to be an
increasing schism between
a major political party in america and
the media
absolutely i know you'll be watching it
closely so thanks again aidan for being
here tonight
and thanks to all of you for watching
and we'll see you next week and finally
thanks to the great team at law and
crime for genius
on the air and guineas off the air
without a hitch
[Music]
foreign